تطوير ايران لبرنامجها نووي يجعل من
العوده لاتفاق عام 2015 مستعصيا المفاوضات
المتوقفه اصلا والنتيجه ضغط اقتصادي اكبر
على طهران المكبله بالعقوبات والعائد
مواطنها للتظاهرات قبل اسابيع احتفل
النظام الايراني بالذكرى الرابعه
والاربعين للثوره وقتها في
1979 كان حوالي عشرين في المئه من
الايرانيين يعيشون تحت خط الفقر الوعود
كانت براقه حينها لكن ماذا عن النتيجه
الفعليه عام 2021 وصلت نسبه من يعيشون تحت
خط الفقر الى 52% وفي العام الماضي فقط
بات ثلث سكان البلاد البالغ عددهم 90
مليون نسمه يعيشون في فقر مدقع الاقتصاد
يعاني وصل الدولار الى 49 الف تومان هذه
الارقام انعكست طبعا على المواطنين ارتفعت
الاسعار بشكل جنوني الايرانيون باتوا غير
قادرين على تلبيه الاحتياجات الاساسيه فن
السبب في كل هذا هل هو قرارات الحكومه
الخاطئه وما الذي اتخذه المسؤولون من
قرارات لمعالجه الامر هذه الاسئله طرحت
على وزير الاقتصاد فكيف كان بده
جزيل الشكر لدي طلب وهو ان ارد على الجزء
الاول من السؤال في المؤتمر المقبل فارجو
ان تتفضلي بتكرار السؤال حتى اجلب معي
الارقام لتساعد على تصحيح التحليلات في
الفضاء الافتراضي والاجتماعي في البلد
لانني لم اكن مستعدا للرد على هذا السؤال
لا يملك المسؤول الرد فمن اذا لديهن اجابه
ربما نعرف من خطابا سري للغايه ارسله
الامين العام لمجلس الامن القومي الايراني
علي شمخاني للرئيس ابراهيم رئيس في الخامس
من فبراير اعترف شمخاني لرئيسي ان طهران
تواجه ازمه كبيره في السلع الاساسيه قطاع
الخاص الايرانيين لم يبرم عقودا مع بائعين
اجانب للاشهر المقبله رساله اخرى اختلف
مرسلها لكن محتواها لم يتغير في ديسمبر
الماضي رئيس استخبارات الحرس الثوري محمد
كاظمي لرسالته الى محمد مخبر النائب الاول
لرئيسي حذره من التهديد الخطر الذي يواجهه
الامن الغذائي للمجتمع الايراني
هذه الرسائل تاتي متزامنه مع شح كبير في
عدد من السلع الاساسيه وزياده اسعار البعض
الاخر بشكل كبير ولناخذ بعض الامثله الذره
مثلا اثرت سياسه النظام في الحرب
الاوكرانيه على توفرها في السوق الايرانيه
كيف ترفض بيع الذره لطيران بسبب دعم
الاخير العسكري لروسيا بالطائرات المسيره
منتجات اخرى ارتفعت اسعارها وبشكل جنوني
ومنها اللحوم سعر الكيلو تجاوز 500
بعض المواطنين قرروا عدم الشراء بينما
البعض الاخر اتجه الى التقسيط عدد من
الصحف تناولت قصه غلاء الاسعار وتحديدا
اللحوم والدواجن مثل صحيفه تعادل
الاقتصاديه وصحيفه سانداتكي الاصلاحيه
لتنهالتهم بتشويش الراي العام ونقل محتوى
مغاير للواقع لجنه الرقابه على وسائل
الاعلام اوقفت صحيفه سازانتكي لتقصي
الحقيقه سنذهب لعدد من المدن ومنها مشهد
حاضنه النظام ومسقط راس
انفجار السيده جهاز لهذه فاك برايه خليج
الجوش بموتن الميه
بدون انه المشهد